c'est bien moi qui vous ai vu à la
télévision des plus grands acteurs
français total
m
le vrai et vous tête l'artiste n'est ce
pas je suis comédien arthur et j'ai
cessé de l'être par un petit moment que
j'ai été j'étais la couleur du vent le
fer avec l'apple app étrangers
c'est que vous êtes maître dans beaucoup
de choses je ne serais pas un peu maître
chanteur non je suis un acteur qui
chante ça je le sais vous avez vous
écrit n'est ce pas vous avez écrit un
livre sur des choses
portrait de l'artiste à la tête coupée
bah oui quand on est acteur on n'a pas
grand chose à faire
j'écris des choses que je chante je vais
revivre dont une partie est chantée
enfin été chantée accuse carrache
antérieures les ivrognes me pose t'on
les gens comme pas nous mais est ce
qu'il ya un dieu prose oui oui on
regarde pas de bondues où il ya pas dire
sinon je serais pas là où il n'ya pas de
dieu me dites pas que c'est triste à vie
d'artiste quand même à vous voir non
ignorons
j'ai pas des plus gaies
mais y'a pas dit non plus
aussi plein de tristesse par
d'augmentation vous ne pouvez pas un peu
un peu dommage que au pays des affreux
le népal est sur la voie non au pays des
aveugles les borgnes sont rois voilà
on sait mieux
au pays des ivoiriens les aveugles
francs ont perdus au pays des mes palais
la fronde des rois je vous le demande et
il a été dans les aurès je vous croyais
votre français sera un bon coeur mais
fracturée au 18e j'ai joué l'abbé de
cours peu d'alcool mais ne rend pas il
fera pas je suis un curé non non c'est
un militant je vous le demande lequel
des deux le fini pour le françois a le
plus aidé françois à être célèbre
l'ajout par en course de vélo alors je
vais dire que le dixième de ce que j'en
pense à apporter à l'humanité à part aux
bijouteries lebel maire de la face
oui une fois ce qu'il m'a dit je peux
vous dire la jeune femme étudiante cé
philippe je mesure la force d'une idée à
la résistance qu'elle me pose c'est
chacun s'applique c'est à soi même ça va
vous donc je vous ai fait mal
vous êtes monarchie dit oui ça vous fait
quoi alors comprenez moi relate 89
l'hécatombe ça vous fait quel effet ça
me fait gerber
je trouve un petit peu
dégoûtant que
donc on célèbre un petit peu comme ça
c'est bon sens oui je vais vous demander
ses initiales de bm cigale à quillan rpr
et notre fille son père et sa pourrais
je partis royal ils seront d'après vous
non il n'ya pas de parti royaliste
il ya que l'héritage d'un pouvoir alors
là je vous met dans la merde c'est du
plus tard huit mois pour voir si vous
êtes vraiment hectares allez-y là je
vous écoute
2 - ouais je vous dis adieu pour douch
allait pour nous ça va je disais à
plaisir par son contenu
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars d'études
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus